because when you see regret in a man's
eyes it's [ __ ] painful because you
can't do [ __ ] about it when you're 90
and you're not mobile and you're tired
and it's over you can't do it you can't
do it you can't build that company
wanted you can't spend that time with
your kid you its regret and it [ __ ]
drives the [ __ ] out of me no look I
think failure has to be quantified if
you fail that you've never can get up
from it again you know that's not a good
failure I think I think failure and
adversity are the two things I think
about for me as an entrepreneur and very
entrepreneurial and always in my own
stuff all the failures along the way
even going back to like the baseball
card show when I was 13 that I pay $400
for a table and nobody showed up to that
baseball card I was a learning lesson
those micro failures were super super
important I think you know it depends on
your stomach right like if you if you
really don't like go out of business
I think people take one of two ways
right they're like just finished and
they're never able to get off the mat
and they go in a different direction so
to me I think quantifying the failure
supported me I got a change you got
involved like Madonna did it right she
reinvented herself 14 times that's why
she had a long career you know like
you've got to reinvent yourself you know
so I let's talk about sports when you're
the best athlete and you're like the guy
and you're like one of top 15 players
draymond Green
he's my buddy Tremont really worked on
his game every offseason you know uh
Ricky Rubio the flashy point guard from
Minnesota if he developed his outside
shot he would have been a much bigger
player he had all the passing skills the
quickness he's got everything if instead
of going to Ibiza and [ __ ] chicks in
the offseason he worked on his 18-foot
jumper he'd be
in the game if you have ambition your
actions have to match that and too many
people are just like not putting in the
work their mouth is way ahead of their
[ __ ] we you know actions like really
you're gonna be the greatest NBA player
of all time why because you think you
got a little handle on the weekends you
need to shoot 15,000 free-throws before
school every day what can you do from
Friday 5:00 p.m. until Monday 7:00 a.m.
I'm just curious like and I don't think
you shouldn't have a weekend but I think
everybody's ambition actually is more
predicated on their actions than their
words my friends tell me all the time
they're so ambitious and I'm like if
that's true then you punt leisure and
you punt concerts at Jones Beach and you
work I realize what's going on here one
life I realize that I'm living like this
is our only at-bat and most of you are
in people [ __ ] walking around here
like they're coming back look walking
around you're like they're coming back
you're not coming back well listen I
don't want to impose my beliefs on
others maybe you do need to come back I
believe you come back to come back as a
tree or a flower pot or d-roc sneakers
and that blows the air
and so I'm acting that way I'm acting
that way
[Music]